let's think about what might happen to
the boiling point or the freezing point
of any solution if we start adding
particles or we start adding solute to
it and for our i guess just our
visualization let's just think about
water again it doesn't have to be water
can be any solvent but let's just think
about water in its liquid state
the particles are reasonably
disorganized but they're they're because
of their kinetic energy but they still
have that hydrogen bonds that that wants
to make them be near each other so this
is in the liquid state and they have a
reasonable amount of kinetic energy
you know each of these particles is
moving in some direction rubbing against
each other bouncing off of each other
now to move it into the solid state
or to freeze it what has to happen
the ice has to enter kind of a
crystalline structure it has to get
pretty
organized so let's say it has to look
something like this
the water molecules are going to have a
regular structure where the hydrogen
bonds dominate
any kind of kinetic movement they want
to do and all the kinetic movement
they're just vibrating in place so you
have to get a little bit orderly
right there
right and then you know obviously this
lattice structure goes on and on with a
gazillion of
of water molecules
but the interesting thing is is that
this somehow has to get organized so
what happens if we start introducing
molecules into this water let's say the
example of of of sodium actually i won't
do any example let's just say some
arbitrary molecule if i were to
introduce it there if i were to put
something let me draw it again so now
i'll just use that same if i were to
introduce some molecules and let's say
they're pretty large so they bump
they push all of these
water molecules out of the way so the
water molecules are now on the outside
of that and let's say i have another one
that's over here
some relatively large molecules of
solute relative to water that's because
the water molecule really isn't
that big now do you think it's going to
be easier or harder to freeze this are
you going to have to remove more or less
energy to get to a frozen state well
because these molecules they they're not
going to be part of this lattice
structure because frankly they wouldn't
even fit into it they're actually going
to make it harder for these water
molecules to get organized because these
you know to get organized they have to
get it you know the right distance for
the hydrogen bonds to form but in this
case even as you start removing heat
from the system you know maybe the ones
that aren't near that aren't near the
that aren't near the the solute
particles they'll start to organize with
each other
they'll start to organize with each
other but then when you introduce a
solute particle let's say a solid
particle sitting right here
it's going to be very hard for someone
to organize with this guy to get near
enough for the hydrogen bond to start
taking hold
so these would be this distance would
make it very difficult and so
the way i think about it is that these
solute particles make the structure
irregular or they add more disorder and
we'll eventually talk about entropy and
all of that but they they make it more
regular and it's making it harder to get
into a regular form and so the the
intuition is is that this should
lower the boiling point or make it sorry
lower the melting point so salute
solute
particles
make it a make you have a lower
lower boiling point where you have to go
let's say if we're talking about water
at standard temperature and pressure or
at one atmosphere then instead of going
to zero degrees you might have to go to
negative one or negative two degrees and
we're going to talk a little bit about
what that is
now what's the intuition of what what
this will do when you when you want to
go into a gaseous state when you want to
boil it so the
you know my initial gut was hey i'm
already in a disordered state which is
closer to what a gas is so wouldn't that
make it easier to boil but it turns out
it also makes it harder to boil and this
is how i think about it remember
everything with boiling deals with
what's happening at the surface
and we talked about that when our vapor
pressure so at the surface we said
you know if i have a bunch of water
molecules
in the liquid
state we knew that although the average
temperature might not be high enough for
for the water molecules to evaporate
that there's a distribution of kinetic
energies and some of these water
molecules on the surface because the
surface ones are might be going fast
enough to escape
and when they escape
into the into vapor then they create a
vapor pressure above here and if that
vapor pressure is high enough they can
kind of you can almost view them as
linemen blocking the way for more
molecules to to kind of run behind them
as they block all of the other ambient
air pressure above them
so these molecules start if there's
enough of them and they have enough
energy they can start to push back
or to push outward is the way i think
about it so that more guys can come in
behind them so i hope that linemen
analogy doesn't completely lose you
now what happens if you were to
introduce solute into it you know some
of the solute particle might be down
here probably doesn't have much of an
effect
down here but some of it's going to be
bouncing on the surface
so they're going to be taking up some of
the surface area
and because and this is at least how i
think of it since they're we're taking
up some of the surface area it's going
to be you're going to have less surface
area exposed to the solvent particle or
to the solution or the stuff that'll
actually vaporize you're going to have a
lower vapor pressure
you're going to have a lower
vapor pressure
and remember your boiling point is when
the vapor pressure when you have enough
particles with enough kinetic energy out
here to start to start pushing against
the atmospheric pressure when the vapor
pressure is equal to the atmospheric
pressure you start boiling but because
of these guys
i have a lower vapor pressure so i'm
gonna have to add even more kinetic
energy more heat to the system in order
to get enough vapor pressure up here to
start pushing back the atmospheric
pressure so
salute also
raises the boiling point
raises boiling point so the way that you
can think about it is salute when you
add something to a solution it's going
to make it want to be in the liquid
state
more whether you lower the temperature
it's going to want to stay in liquid as
opposed to ice and if you raise the
temperature it's going to want to stay
in liquid as opposed to gas
and i found this neat hopefully it shows
up well on this video
i have to give due credit this is from
chem.purdue.edu
slash g
g c help slash solution
html but i thought it was a pretty neat
graphic of or at least a visualization
this is just the surface of water
molecules and it gives you a sense of
you know just how things vaporize as
well is that there's some things on the
surface that just bounce off
and here's an example where they they
visualize sodium chloride at the surface
and because the sodium chloride is kind
of bouncing around on the surface with
the water molecules fewer fewer of those
water molecules kind of have the the
room to escape so the boiling point gets
elevated
now the question is by how much does it
get elevated and this is one of the neat
things in life is that
the answer is actually quite simple
the change in boiling or
or
or freezing point
so the change in
change in temperature of let's say
temperature of
vaporization
is equal to some constant
times the number of moles
the number or the at least the mole
concentration
the molality
times the molality
of the solute that you're putting into
into your solution so for example if i
have
let's say i have
oh i don't know
one
one kilogram of
so let's say my solvent
is water
i'll switch colors it's getting is i and
i have one kilogram of water and let's
say we're just at atmospheric pressure
and let's say i have some sodium
chloride
na
cl
and let's say i have oh i don't know
let's say i have two moles of nacl so
two i'll have two moles
the question is how much will this
raise
raise the the boiling point of this
water so first of all you just have to
figure out the molality
molality
which is just equal to
which is just equal to the number of
moles of solute is two moles
divided by the number of the number of
of of kilograms of solvent so let's say
we have
two kilograms of salt oh sorry one
kilogram of solvent
one kilogram this was of course
moles so our molality is two moles per
kilogram
so
we just have to figure out what this
constant is and then we'll know the
temperature elevation and actually that
same produced site they gave a list of
tables i haven't run the experiments
myself
they have some niche charts here but
they say okay water normal boiling point
is 100 degrees celsius at
standard uh atmospheric pressure and
then they say that the constant is
0.512
celsius degrees per mole so let's just
say 0.5
so it equals 0.5
so k is equal to 0.5
so
and i want to be very clear here because
this is this is a very i wouldn't say a
subtle point but it's an interesting
point so i said that there's two the
molality of i just realized i made a
mistake i said the molality of sodium
chloride is two two moles per kilogram
but that would be if sodium chloride
stayed in its in this in this molecular
state if it stayed together
right but what happens is that the
sodium chloride actually disassociates
and we learned all about in that
previous video it each molecule each
comp each each sodium chloride pair
disassociates into two molecules right
into a sodium
ion and a chloride chlorine
anion and because of that because this
disassociates into two the molality is
actually going to be 2 times the number
of moles of sodium chloride i have so
it's going to be 2 times this so my
molality will actually be 4. this is an
interesting point if i was dealing with
and i wrote it here
so this right here is glucose
and this is
sodium chloride or at least sodium
chloride is crystal form one one
molecule i guess you can view it is or
one salt of it
i guess you could just view it as one of
these little pairs right here but the
interesting thing is is you could have
the same number of moles of sodium
chloride when you viewed as a compound
and glucose but glucose when it goes
into water it just stays as one molecule
of glucose so a mole of glucose will
dissociate into a mole of glucose in
water
i guess it won't disassociate it'll just
stay as one mole while a mole of sodium
chloride will turn to two moles because
it's it disassociates it turns into two
separate particles
so in my example
when i start with a mole of this i end
up actually once i dissolve it in water
i end up with two with a with a two with
two moles per kilogram or sorry four
moles per kilogram of molality because
this turns into two particles so given
that the molality is four moles
right two moles of sodium two moles of
chloride per kilogram
so i just use that
constant that i just got from purdue and
i get the change in temperature
is equal to that constant 0.5
0.5
times
4 which is equal to 2 degrees so my my
boiling point will be elevated by two
degrees now if i had the same number of
moles i've had two moles of
glucose
dissolved into my water i'd only get
half as much half of much of an increase
because the molality would be half as
much because it doesn't turn into two
particles in some textbooks you'll
actually see it written like this
you'll actually see the same formula
written like change
in
boiling temperature or vapor per
temperature or whatever you want is
equal to k
times m times i where they'll say this
is the molality of the
of the compound you're talking about so
in this case this would this number
would be 2. and then this is and then i
is the number of of molecules or the
number of things that it disassociates
into so in this case this would have
been due
and that's where we would have gotten
four times k which is 0.5 which is 2. in
the case of water this would be sorry in
the case of the glucose this would still
be two but it only turns into one
particle when it goes into water so that
would be one so you'd only have a one
degree increase in the in the boiling
point of water now freezing point is the
same thing
change in freezing point
change in freezing point is also
proportional to
the molality and you can either say the
molality of the original non-in water
compound times the number of compounds
it disassociates into although these
this k is going to be different for
freezing as it than it is for for
boiling and of course this k changes at
different pressures and for for
different elements but the really big
takeaway is just to realize that even if
you have a mole of this and a mole of
that and they're going to be dissolved
into the same amount of water because
this dissociates into two particles and
this dissociates into one for every or
this associates into two moles for every
mole of the crystal you have this only
this doesn't disassociate it just stays
as one this will have twice as large of
an effect on the freezing point change
or on the boiling point elevation than
the glucose will